[Music]
hi alex how are you
hi hey how are you guys doing better
than i deserve how can we help
um i have a little bit of a unique
question for you
so i am 26 years old
um i have about 190 000
saved up between like 401k and also
cash um and this year i'm looking to
purchase
my first rental property not within new
york city
but in a town where my family lives and
it has something about like a
12 to 15 cash on cash return this year
um but that would require approximately
call it 45 000
put in terms of like a down payment
maintenance etc for the property
um i've been dating a woman for about
two years
right now um and we're starting to get
like incredibly serious when it comes to
where we want to take our relationship
um she has approximately eighty thousand
dollars worth of debt
and currently works as a preschool
teacher making about forty thousand
dollars a year
i'm wondering um do you think it is wise
for me to
basically take on her debt um if we
decide to get
married over the next year as we're
doing towards the stage where we want to
move towards engagement
and do you think that i should basically
delay purchasing the property for the
next two to three years
in order to make sure that we if we got
nearly could pay down
her debts well it's not only wise it's
what's going to happen
if you marry her you get what you get
all of her dude
it's simple it's pretty simple i mean
even if you said i'm not going to help
you your little preschool
income is going to have to pay off all
this and you're going to spend the next
42 years of your life toiling through it
while i go over here and invest in real
estate
that crap ain't gonna work man that's
just not gonna work
so uh it's not gonna work relationally
it's not gonna work financially it's not
gonna work anything so
if if you're going to marry this lady
you better be ready to write a check
when you come home for the honeymoon for
80 grand and you're ready and that means
you're going to delay your investment
property because you fell in love good
for you
so this is basically shopping investing
right now
holding off just saving the cash for the
next three years putting it in something
reasonably safe
knowing that like the first thing that
we're doing to merge finances
in two years is take care of the debts
and then just
you got it figured out man uh so
and so now comes the the question is she
worth it
[Laughter]
are you worth it
oh i love this